This is my officialer, and I'm at the home of Gene Starker Roth.
Today is October 31st, October 31st, 2007, and Gene and I are going to be talking about
the years when she was raising a family here in Corvallis, her life with Kermit,
and that section of her life.
And you did a great job in your interview with Wade telling about how you met Kermit.
So I don't want to make you repeat that story, but it is a wonderful story about how you
came together, but I'd like to know a little bit more.
The questions that he didn't ask you are the kinds of questions that a woman has
a tendency more to ask in terms of what it was about him that attracted you.
And how you knew he was the right man for you at the very early days there.
Well, I had been dating a lot of boys out at not only at Kermit, but also in part
in Australia at the US, and officers clubs up there.
And I don't know when I met Kermit, we just hit it off and we the first date that we had
after the original date in the effort fraternity has.
We just talked and talked and talked and everything was just, you know, we agreed
on a lot of things.
He was an easy person to spend time with.
Yes, that's right.
So I think that that, and of course he was tall and he was good looking.
Lots of people said that he looked just like Gary Cooper.
In fact, when I obtained his picture to put in my apartment in Australia, when I had
people come and say, why do you have Gary Cooper's picture in your room?
Wow, that's quite a statement.
And also after we were married, sometimes we go to a gas station and the gas station
boys would come up and then after they put the gas in several times this happened,
they would knock on my door and they said, did anybody ever tell you,
or has been looks like Gary Cooper?
Well, that's quite a compliment.
So you dated for about a year before you got married?
No, we met in September because that was state fair and PI, which was Pacific International.
That was a big thing with extension and then at Thanksgiving,
he planted his paternity pin and at Christmas, we announced our engagement.
And we were married in June.
That's a pretty quick turnaround.
So it was September that you met him.
You must have been pretty sure then he was the right man.
Yes, that's right.
There was never any doubt in my mind.
Well, we're some of the things that you did together in that for those first six months that helped
to secure your relationship.
Well, I think that we spent a lot of time with our families.
I think that was very educational because from then on, from the time we met,
he would come to Astoria.
And I had an apartment in a big old, what do I want to say out?
It was a very old house and the people that I lived with had two little girls.
And I think they wanted me to live there because I could occasionally babysit if they wanted to go to a late movie.
They knew I was home and could watch the girls.
But we stuck.
I lost some of the things that you spent the time with your family.
Yes.
Well, he would come up and they offered for him to stay in their bedroom, a bedroom adjoining my unit.
And then the next weekend we'd go to his mother's house and can be meet there.
And then the next weekend we'd come down to Curve Allison.
He was at the fraternity and I was with my parents.
I think in those days you didn't live together.
No, for you married.
Absolutely not.
But we were at one of our, one of those three places every weekend from that time on.
Yeah.
So your parents got to know him pretty quickly.
Yes, yes.
How did they like him?
They thought he was fine.
They didn't like him from the start, huh?
Never really discussed it.
But I remember very distinctly saying,
Now if you have any, I'm going to marry this man if you got any objections.
Tell me now.
I'm saying.
Well, I'm like you had gotten pretty bold over the years.
You've come a long way from.
Yeah.
From those early days.
So he was still going to school at that time.
Yes, because he had started school.
And do you want me to tell you a little bit about his background?
Absolutely.
Okay.
Well, Kermit was raised in Monmouth because his father was a superintendent of schools there.
And I guess that Kerval has played Monmouth in football and he played football.
But I didn't know a man.
And then he, his father wanted to get his doctor to agree.
So Kermit joined the three C.
Well, he went to school, I think, one term.
And then his dad didn't have enough money to go and get a doctorate.
So Kermit joined the three Cs.
And he sent his money home from that.
So his dad could get his doctorate.
And then was right after high school?
Yes.
Then his father did get his doctorate.
And they, but it was during the war by then.
And he was asked to go to Portland to teach.
Well, there's, how to, how to not only, well, no.
That's, that's right.
He was asked to teach.
Well, there's how to teach.
Well, there's.
Because they a lot of them knew how to well.
But they couldn't teach people how to well.
So he, he was employed to do that.
To teach.
And then Kermit went in the service.
And his father died while he was overseas.
So the Red Cross flew him home.
And I didn't know him at this point in life.
And then his mother had always taught school.
And she moved to can be and bought a house.
And it was a four or five bedroom house.
And she took in teachers because she was so lonely.
And that developed when we were married.
And then she died when we had to get a house.
We had to buy a house that fit our furniture.
Because she had all these beds and mattresses.
Oh, that's human heritage.
So we, we inherited all her furniture.
I couldn't start at the rooming house yourself.
That's right.
But we, the bedding and all of that was so good to, you know, just give away.
So we tried to keep it.
And of course eventually we used it with all our kids.
That's a good thing.
Yeah.
So what was, where was Kermit in the war?
He was, he was tinny in, which is a little island about a mile by a mile and a half.
Very close to,
Oh, I'll have to think about that.
I'll have to get you the name of that.
But you know, if you heard it, it was very much in the news.
But it was a small island.
And, but they, there were japs on it.
And they never knew when they were going to run into somebody who was hiding in that island.
Uh-huh.
But that was when he learned to a scuba dive because he was a mechanic repairing airplanes that had been shot down.
And so he took the plexiglass and made a mask and took the rubber off the tires.
And it blown and made the back of the mask.
And he made quite a little money during that period because he would dive for shells.
Oh, interesting.
And I had, I don't know, how many shoe boxes of shells would, when we were married.
He brought those with him.
So he took advantage of being in a tropical location.
Yes, he did.
And he always blessed the government for sending him to a warm climate because he said that he never would have survived in Europe with a cold.
Yeah, I did.
He did like to be cold.
So he was with the air force.
Yes.
But he didn't fly.
He was always in the canning.
Well, he intended to fly.
But the time he got through is schooling.
They didn't need pilots anymore.
And he had, of course, a very, he was a very handy man.
And he knew how to fix anything.
So they put him in a good job for him.
That sounds good.
But he did have to do some combat.
No, not really.
It was never a shooting person.
He just worked on the airplanes.
But when they walked around the island, they were exposed to japs sometimes.
And I know he said that he got some holes to hide in.
If they were around.
But he wasn't in a situation where he was particularly traumatized.
When he came back, he was in pretty good shape.
Well, he was in pretty good shape.
But he told me that when he came back and, of course, he'd lost his dad.
And so his mother wanted a lot of things done around the house.
And he said he didn't go out at all.
He just wanted to stay home.
So he did a lot of repair work around the house that you wanted done for.
I think it was over six months that he just didn't do anything.
Yeah, he needed to make a transition.
Yes.
And then when he came back to school,
he was ready to get on with his life.
And he, his goal when he came back to school was to get a Tomlinson commission.
And it must be a thing of the past because I asked some military men not long ago
if they knew what a Tomlinson commission was.
And they didn't know anything about it.
But as I understood it at the time, it was a commission given to people
with proper qualifications that would give them a permanent place in the military,
not a reserve commission, which most of the kids who go through ROTC receive.
Right.
So that was quite an honor to get that.
And then we were going to be married in June.
And he received the Tomlinson commission just in very short time.
Maybe maybe the middle of May.
Before we were to be married.
And he said, he never consulted me.
But he just said, I just figured you wouldn't make a very good military wife.
And I turned it down.
That's interesting.
Now, why do you think he thought that was it the moving around part that he thought you would see?
I think so.
And I also think that he blamed it on me a little bit.
But I think that the time he decided to get married that he wanted to be settled down.
He didn't want to travel.
So I think it was a little bit of a...
Yeah.
That's a hard life for early that.
Yes, it is.
So what was his major in college?
In industrial engineering.
Industrial engineering.
Interesting.
I didn't realize that.
And he worked for a high-stir company.
The first year or so we moved after we went on our honeymoon.
Well, I don't know whether I covered this with weight or not.
We were...he was commissioned in the morning.
And he got the Tomons of Commission.
At noon, he was graduated from Oregon State.
And it was a hundred and seven degree in courvelles.
At that time, they graduated from the men's gym, which is now something else.
And they had ice.
Big 50,000 bucks of ice in all the windows.
To try and cool things.
And I remember looking at his collar.
He had perspired clear through all his collar.
And then we were married in the evening.
Oh my god.
That was a big day.
Was.
Had you planned it that way?
Yes.
Did you know the situation was going to happen with things?
Oh, that sounds like a stressful, stressful way to do things.
But after the honeymoon, why were we?
And that was also a little crisis because we had the vanport flood at that moment.
Tell me what it is.
So we were going to up to quit late-quenalt.
We had to get up to Washington.
And so Kermit said, well, we were going to spend the first night in Salem.
Because we didn't want to drive very far.
And after the wedding and all the day we'd had.
So.
And there was a thunderstorm that night because of the heat.
And when we drove up the highway, there were power lines coming down and
flopping on the highway.
And I thought, oh, we're going to get electrocuted before we forever have a honeymoon.
But we did.
We made it to Salem.
Then we knew that the bridges in part were all closed.
So the only way to get north was through long view are bridge of the gods.
And so he said, which do you want to do?
And I said, well, we're off on a holiday.
Let's just go to the bridge of the gods.
I've never been across the bridge of the gods.
And he said, OK, so we went up there.
And we came around and we got as far as.
Some place in Washington.
I can't remember the name.
The river is close to there.
It was something K.
I could look on a map and find it.
But anyway, we got that far.
And the town was underwater.
So then we had to turn around.
Go back over the bridge of the gods down to long view and then across.
Wow.
And we called that wet flood.
The then port flood.
And that was a big nature.
It was where a lot of people lived during the war.
It was kind of low income housing.
And it all flooded.
And you're never heard of that.
I'm embarrassed to say that.
Well, it's very, very well known.
Like a lot of people.
Uh-huh.
So the section of Portland.
Yes.
It was out by Jensen Beach.
Uh-huh.
Oh, look that up and read about a little bit.
So anyway, you were going to tell me a little bit about your wedding.
Oh, yes.
It was at the Presbyterian territory.
Sure.
That's correct.
At first, I said to my parents that I don't want to be married in the Presbyterian church
because at that time it's been remodeled since it was pretty Barney.
And that cold I felt.
And I just didn't want to be married there.
Well, we got to looking at the wedding list.
And of course, Kermit's family was from Modemuth.
And my family had lived here forever.
And the guest list was getting so big that that was about the only place that we could
have the wedding.
So bless my father.
He decided that he could fix it.
So that morning he and I don't know who else.
I wasn't aware of it all going on.
But somebody helped him and they brought in about 50 fur trees.
There were a lot of them.
And they put it all around the front of the church.
I mean, and it was so hot that it was in June when the new growth was on the fur trees.
And so they wilted and it looked like a little ornament on each limb of the trees.
It was just beautiful.
And this was on the inside of the church.
Yes.
They brought them all in and put them up.
And the church side the church.
And as I say, all the fur trees because it was so hot, they just wilted.
And all those little new growth on it just hung down.
And they looked like a little ornament.
It was just really quite effective.
And then we had white.
One of those white flowers that you take to San Beteries in June.
From Memorial Day.
For San Fums.
Not for San Fums.
I don't know either.
But I can look it up.
Okay.
Almost need you to do that.
But then we both.
Well, I may be able to think of it before we get through.
But anyway, it was really pretty all white.
And then the shades of green.
Oh, yeah.
It was really quite lovely.
People were quite impressed by it.
Yes.
And so perfect for your family.
It was.
It's a nice pigment.
So tell me about your dress.
Was it something that?
Well, I made my dress.
You know, in those days, there were the bridal
stores that there are now.
And I wanted to wear my mother's wedding dress.
But it was too small.
My mother was a very petite lady when she was married.
But she had a lot of lace on her dress and also on the veil.
So I took the lace and put some sheer yolk on my dress.
And that the lace was from her wedding dress.
So it was quite a sentimental affair.
Oh, yeah.
But I made it because I, you know, was a homey condom.
It was a nice sewed and there were patterns and sewing books to use.
So it worked out just fine.
And then the, I, her veil had been kind of eaten.
You know, through the years with different, I suppose,
pause or something.
I don't know.
And anyway, I use the, all the lace from her veil around the edge of my veil.
So I thought that was quite nice.
Yeah, but some very touching.
Was it a large group?
Was it your family or were there friends and community members too?
Well, there weren't too many because there was my father's sister and her husband.
And then my, my grandmother was my father's mother was alive at that time.
And her wish was that she lived to see me married.
And she got her wish. She came in a wheelchair.
And, and she, she couldn't see very well.
But we had a nice conversation.
And, during our honeymoon, she died.
And so we had to come home from our honeymoon to go to her funeral.
Wonderful that she got her wish.
Yes.
So, you know, there's so much planning and such that goes into weddings these days.
It seems like it's just a huge endeavor.
Did you have a big build-up to it?
I mean, we...
Well, no, I think in those days, it wasn't a three day affair like it is now.
No, we just, well, as I say, we were pretty busy all day.
But we just had the wedding and then reception.
And people didn't stay long at that reception.
It was too hot.
But we had cake.
I think we just had cake and punch.
Uh-huh.
There at the church.
Well, that sounds just right because then you could get out and get on your way.
Yes.
So, you know, now they do a breakfast after the wedding and all that stuff.
And dinner beforehand.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, no.
My daughter went to a wedding not so long ago.
It was in a while.
They had a big groom's dinner.
I...
Yes, my folks did a groom's dinner the night before.
Uh-huh.
And we had a lot of the fraternity boys and some of the family.
But they were only just those few people.
I don't think my grandmother came to that because she was too frail.
But we did have... and they gave it because her mother was in... she lived in Canby.
Mm-hmm.
So, it wasn't convenient for her to do it.
And in those days, we didn't go to restaurants.
It was all done in your home.
Sure.
Uh-huh.
So, you know, we only had just one or two restaurants in Corvalle.
Custards in and out.
The gables.
That was about it.
It was an original.
Mm-hmm.
Interesting.
Has... have any of... did either of your daughters use your dress as a wedding dress?
No.
They never did.
They wanted their own.
Uh-huh.
Do you still have that dress?
Yes, I do.
I... I hope I'll have a picture of you and your dress in this.
It won't fit now.
I don't do it.
I don't mean a girl.
I don't know.
But I... but I do have a picture.
Yeah.
Good.
Wonderful.
Ah.
So, you went off and did your honeymoon and then um... he ended up in a first job in Portland
and how did he get that job with Heister?
Well, I think through the college and those days we... they had placement people.
Uh, I know I was placed in a job by a placement person on the campus.
Uh-huh.
And I presume that's how he got his job and he worked for Heister for...
Uh...
We lived there.
We lived in an apartment.
A very small apartment for a few months.
Permits mothers wanted to do three things before she died.
And I'll try to remember what they were.
Uh-huh.
She wanted to go down to see her other son Norman who was lived in California.
She wanted to fly in an airplane.
Uh-huh.
That was the third thing she wanted to do.
Well, she did all three anyway, whatever they were.
That might come to you too.
And so she said, why don't you and Kermit live in my house while I go do these things?
And because she spent probably a month maybe more down in California.
And she had a garden.
She was a great gardener.
And of course, can be soil is wonderful for gardens.
And so we stayed at the house and took care of the garden.
And I did a lot of canning for her and got things, you know, made use of what was in the garden.
And then she came home.
And I had an offer.
I think maybe I told Wade this.
I had an offer to go down to the dals.
And do a, sometimes I have trouble with getting the right words out.
I was judging her fair.
So I said to her, wouldn't you like to go with me and be a nice trip for you.
And I'm just going for the day.
And she said, oh, she'd love to.
Well, she went with me.
And I judged pillow slips among them.
The broader pillow slips among many other things.
And I gave first prize to the white embroidered pillow slips.
Because a lot of the women had done magic colored ones.
And they were pretty bad.
Excuse me.
Hello.
Yes.
Yes, Rebecca.
How are you this month?
Well, I'm fine, Rebecca.
But I have a lady sitting here now that's doing an interview with me.
So I really can't talk.
Oh, good.
Good.
Well, now, when are you in a week from Friday?
Okay.
Well, would you put a little tickler on your counter to call me when you get home?
But I can come down and talk with you.
Okay.
Thanks.
Oh, we had a good time.
Didn't we?
I did.
Okay.
Bye.
Sorry.
It's great.
All right.
You gave the prize to the white pillow slips.
Yes.
So anyway, there was quite some discussion, apparently, about this judge who was doing this.
And she sat in the corner and listened to her new daughter-in-law, you know, being criticized.
She could hardly wait to get in the car and tell me that these women had said.
And she was just laughing.
And she just thought that was a fun example.
They think it could get that excited about their real police.
She had quite a sense of humor.
We got along just great.
Well, the shame that you didn't get to spend more time with her.
Yes.
And then I suppose we better put in something about how she died because it wasn't more than a couple
of months.
I forgot when she died.
But she didn't last more than a couple months after she came home.
And we got a call when we were in Portland.
We had moved from the house where we lived.
Well, she was away.
And we got in a department in Portland.
We lived where the safe way is now in Lloyd-Sitter.
And we got a call one morning about five, third year, six.
And the land ladies, you know, telephones were hard to get right after the war.
And she had no telephone in her house.
And we had no telephone in our house in our apartment.
But the land lady called and she tapped on her door.
And she said, your mother is had a heart attack and you need to go.
And so we just dressed and left.
And we got there.
She had the heart attack and got up and tried to make it over to the neighbors.
But had fallen in her garden.
And the neighbors had found her early in the morning, fortunately.
And so they got her back into the house and in bed.
And of course we got there and called the doctor.
And you know what we know about heart now is just, it's just like night and day.
Because we didn't know the minutes where seconds were important at that time.
And the doctors at that era in that era made house calls.
So the doctor came to the house.
And of course by that time, you know, she was, had quite a lot of problems.
Well, she lasted about two or three days.
I remember Kermit went back to our apartment to clean out the refrigerator and get things squared away.
Because we just left and bring some clothes for us to wear.
And so when he was gone to Portland to get those things taken care of, she had another attack.
And then I was feeding her some applesauce because I had made some from her own apples.
And she said, oh, that smells so good.
I would just like to have a taste.
And so I said, well, fine, I'll fix you some.
And I was feeding her and all of a sudden she just just died.
And so Kermit came home about the time that that happened.
And he immediately called the doctor.
And he said, well, she's gone.
Hello.
Hi there.
How are you?
Good.
But I'm with a lady here that I need to, she's doing an interview with me.
And I don't have much time to talk, unfortunately.
Where are you now?
Okay.
Well, I'll call you tonight.
I mailed the package to Micah today about the coat.
Yeah, so he'll get it in a couple of days.
Good.
Well, I said, I took all the things off of the batches.
And then I sent it to the cleaners.
So it's already to go.
All right.
Well, I'll try and call you.
Well, it went from five o'clock work.
Okay.
I'll give you a call.
I'm sorry.
That was my grandson.
Wait, all right.
So you were saying that Permock got there just as she passed away.
Yes.
And I didn't know anything about death.
And he held her tongue down.
And you know, it was pretty awful.
So then we had to call his brother in California.
They came up and then we divided all the stuff.
And that's how we got all the furniture.
Because they didn't want the furniture.
They'd been married for a number of years.
And he was the oldest brother in Kermit was the youngest.
So he said, you just take all the furniture.
So that's what we did.
So do you think you said she had some a few wishes of things she wanted to do before you.
She died.
She had a sense that that she would.
I think she knew that.
And I really think that Kermit sense that he was not going to live very long.
Really.
Because he was so always so insisted that I know everything about our business.
And both his parents had died of her daughter.
Oh, heart attack.
His father fell off of.
He was milking a cow and fell off the stool and died.
So, you know, he had bad genes.
Yeah, that's true.
That means a lot.
But she was a delightful person while you knew her.
And did Kermit have that same fun sense if you were a she had?
I don't think it was quite as broad as her sense of humor.
But she got a big kick out of life.
So it was nice to know her briefly.
Yeah.
So there you were in the big city of Portland.
Was it a pretty happening town at the time?
Oh, yes.
I think that I really enjoyed Portland.
I didn't want to move back to Kermit when we finally made that decision.
But Kermit thought it was the thing to do.
We had two children by then.
And he thought it was the thing to do.
And my dad was putting a lot of pressure on him to come back and start a plywood plant.
Oh.
And Kermit had the industrial engineering training.
And so there were 10 men who put their money together and built the plywood plant.
And Kermit designed it and was in charge of it.
He was because the rest of them in all had other jobs.
So he did that for three or four years.
Don't remember just how long.
But then the plywood market went kapoot.
And so they sold it to somebody, can't remember.
So then he Kermit went into partnership with a man Gordon Larson.
And that's, you know, Beverly Larson who runs the Oelville school.
Well, it was her father that was in partnership with Kermit.
And my dad was sort of putting up the money for this.
Well, Gordon had had a meal out.
Well, that's a lie in Pheloma.
He was on the wall port side.
I don't know.
Just, it wasn't very far up that road.
He had always had a song now.
And so.
But they decided they built it down here at 53rd and reservoir road.
And so a Kermit designed that meal.
And then they built it.
And ran it for.
I would say maybe eight or nine years.
And then.
They had a.
I wouldn't say a.
Well, they disagreed on just a little bit about how it should be run.
And so Kermit said he'd like to buy him out.
Gordon didn't have the money to buy him out.
And so.
Kermit did buy the meal out.
And then Gordon died.
Probably.
Maybe six months after that.
That was all settled.
Because of course they had to divide up all the timber land and everything.
They had property.
Uh-huh.
They bought a lot of timber land in order to have timber in the winter time.
When they couldn't log.
Other places.
They bought timber land.
It could be logged in this in the winter time.
So.
That was.
Very fortunate that we got all that done before.
He died.
Yes.
That would have been a mess.
He died of a heart attack to us.
I remember it.
You could check them.
With them about that.
But I think that he did.
So that mills not there anymore is it?
No.
It isn't.
It's.
It's where they started to run shave.
Yeah.
I know there's a little.
Again.
They couldn't do it because it was annexed.
Oh.
Yeah.
I ran the property for a number of years after my husband died.
I rented it out to various people who ran the mail.
And then timber prices weren't very good.
And the last people that owned it.
It was just ready to not be brought anymore.
And so.
One day they were putting in the water.
Pipe down reservoir road.
And then it came into the fairgrounds.
And they wanted some place to dump the dirt.
And so I said, well, dump it in the pond.
Because I just assume fill in those ponds.
Well, it seemed as though that was not the thing to do.
Because there are rules about filling ponds.
I found out.
Well, one day I spent, I don't know how long on the telephone.
I was all one afternoon and into the next day talking to governmental agencies.
And finally, I got a hold of some.
I don't remember which one.
But they said, oh, Mrs. Roth, we don't talk to owners.
We just talked to lawyers.
And that was the living end.
I just decided I wasn't going to have anything to do with that.
So my, I was mupent to my son about it.
And he said, Mom, you should now that stress.
So he said, I'll take over running it.
So anyway, he tried to run it for, I don't know, four or five years.
And he was in California.
And it was just too much.
So he finally sold it.
And that's when they started to run the goats.
And then they found out they couldn't run the goats because it was in,
he had annexed it.
Uh-huh.
And, uh, so now it's in the city, within the city limits.
So they couldn't.
Yeah, yeah.
It's in the city.
Yeah.
That's interesting.
And it's very odd because soon after,
Ken got through, sold it.
It now, they, you know, they put in all that lovely area in front of the
Fairgrounds.
And they've got the dirt over ready.
And they're going to run the street.
Uh, 53rd's going to go up over the railroad.
And they're going to do that right away.
Oh, I didn't realize that.
Huh?
It's interesting.
It's not bad at the city.
Yeah.
One thing after another.
So he, so permanent was, as long as we're talking about his career.
I can ask you the rest of my questions about, about his career.
So he then stayed at that mill.
Till.
I know this.
He wanted himself in 67 then.
And then did he stay with the mill?
All the rest of his life.
Yeah.
So he shut it down after he had run it 12 years.
And we didn't do anything with it.
I guess he, I can't remember whether he rented it to anybody or not.
But he played the stock market.
He was very sharp about it.
He would get up in the morning and look at all the listings in the paper.
And he made a lot of money on the stock market because he just had a feel for it.
One time we bought Fuji photo stock.
And we made a lot of money on that.
Because it was just when it was starting to come into the United States.
So he said, I think we should take a trip.
And I said, well, we made our money on Fuji photo.
I think we should go to Japan.
And so we did.
And that was real fun.
We had a lovely, lovely trip.
So was that when you had all four children.
Did you take children with you on that trip?
Yes.
You did.
Wow.
I guess we can skip to that.
I want to get back to a couple more questions about his progression through his career too.
But I'd love to hear about the Japan trips since we're there.
Well, we got a lady to stay with in the meantime.
My mother had passed away.
And we got a lady to stay with the children.
But she had to also feed my father because he, after my mother died,
the course that day, why I said, both stay for dinner.
And he just kept coming and kept coming.
That lasted 15 years.
He had a regular dinner invitation.
Yes.
I didn't have an invitation, but he had a seat at the table.
Uh-huh.
And that first he lived just through the woods,
between Jackson and Van Buren.
But then later he moved out on to Timion,
addition out on 53rd Street.
And then by that time, Kim was learning to drive.
And so she could go out and get him and bring him in.
Because he wasn't driving by that time.
Yeah.
So he just always came.
That's a nice thing.
That's good.
So you had a woman who stayed in the house.
And she had to feed him too.
Care of things there.
And then the rest of you packed off to Asia.
It's been a very extravagant trip at that time.
Oh, it was.
It was.
Well, we've we've stopped over in.
Uh-huh.
And then we had a couple of days there.
And then we went to Japan.
And then on the way back, we stopped at Bora Bora.
Wow.
How long was the trip altogether?
I think we were going three weeks.
Wow.
That was a pretty long trip.
Yes.
And that was, was it your first time out of the country, right?
Well, we've been to Hawaii a couple of times.
So you've done some flying.
Yes.
Because we took the all the family to Hawaii a couple of times.
So was it was current more of a traveler?
Since he'd done his stint there.
He really enjoyed the trip to Japan.
He just thought he didn't have any desire to go to Europe at all.
I think he'd heard too many tales during the war of the hardships in Europe with the military.
And so, but he really, I don't know why, but he just thought that Japan was great.
Interesting.
And it's.
So having been in the second world war and over in that part of the world war, was it hard for him to embrace the Japanese?
Did he feel any prejudices?
No, it seemed to be.
He didn't seem to have any feelings about the Japanese.
We were there during.
What do they call that when we have the world?
It was a.
The world's fair.
World's fair.
That's what it was.
And of course, we were so tall that the Japanese we.
We'd hold our hands out like this and the Japanese would get under our arms and then they
They want their pictures taken.
We were so tall.
Oh, that sounds wonderful.
And what an express for your children.
To be able to see that.
Well, they showed.
We've showed them the pictures, of course, when we got home, but they didn't.
But so the children didn't go.
No, no, it was just a no.
The babysitter stayed and took care of them.
I don't care of everybody.
I see.
I think.
Well, I want to ask you some more about some of your.
I'm going to try to travel.
But so we don't get too off course here.
I'm going to take us back to where we were when you were talking.
I just wanted to finish up learning a little bit about Kermit's career because you.
You've been talking about that.
And what I wondered was when it was that he started getting involved in in property management,
how we how we move from being an industrial engineer to.
Yes.
The lumber business.
That's quite a transition there.
Yes.
It was.
Well, I told you that my mother had died.
There.
And I had inherited the by-mark property through the.
My mother's part when she died.
And so my dad had given me that property.
In exchange for.
Some property that he had.
And that's.
10 21.
Real estate exchange.
And that's how that came about.
I did that.
And that's probably he's more known for.
That in the United States and not for.
Then for his forestry.
Are you familiar with that?
Well, when I first started looking researching your family a little bit before I started.
I looked and I did find that that many references on the internet to.
To TJ Starker have to do with that real estate.
Yeah.
That was.
Decided and then has been sort of the standard then from then on.
Yes.
Yeah.
And so we had.
We inherited that.
And then we bought.
Several when he was working with the stock market.
We bought several pieces of property.
And.
In turn.
Did some.
10 31 exchanges with that.
And we always traded up.
And so we just.
You know, that was our income was because we didn't have anything.
We we had to have some flow.
But when Kermit died.
There was not much.
Property that was giving me any.
Real secure monthly.
Well, money flow.
And so that's when when I started doing the.
Real estate because I traded that some of the timber land that was left over from.
From the mail.
Mm hmm.
I've traded that for real estate.
And that.
I would really like to.
And I have some emphasis put on that because.
When my father died, he left me.
I think.
Mm hmm.
In fact, on in his well, it says to my daughter, Jane, I leave.
I think.
His.
His whole.
Point in establishing his.
Timmer.
Was to create a.
A starker for us.
What would you say?
Like a theater.
Yes.
That was.
And he didn't want it broken up.
Mm hmm.
So he didn't.
And everybody thinks I got some money from him and that's how I got started.
But that's not the way it was.
He wanted all that to be kept within the structure of the business.
That's right.
Interesting.
Hmm.
And you know, I could be better.
But.
It's.
I don't know what I did with that piece of paper.
I have two things that I think I'd like to put in this.
Uh.
Because that's what I live by.
And I wrote that out.
Well, although when I go out to the kitchen before you leave and see.
Because I wrote those things down.
One is something about it's worded better than I can't word it.
But it's something about if you have an asset in a container.
It's sometimes eats at the container that it's in.
And uh, yeah, there's another one about there.
And I think that's very true.
I could be really bitter.
Yes.
And I could be very upset with my grandmothers, my nephews.
They had nothing to do with it.
Right.
It was all my dad's.
Object to.
Leave that as a unit.
Hmm.
And he didn't want.
And he didn't really appreciate women either, you know.
Yeah.
He didn't like the fact that women were in the forestry school.
Hmm.
And he didn't really like my sister-in-law.
Got interested in the, in the timber business.
And he really didn't like that either.
Hmm.
He just, he was a German.
Yeah.
Very traditional.
Hmm.
The oldest son.
Yep.
Yeah.
That's, like you can say, that's a longstanding tradition of patriarchy.
That's right.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Well, you did very well.
Yeah.
Probably by German's hard work in the stock market and buying things at the right time
and anything.
Right.
And does the Roth property services business still exist?
Yes.
That's what I do.
I do three times a week.
I work at that.
I have a bookkeeper that comes and keeps track of things.
And I manage the properties.
Hmm.
So how did you learn how to do all that real estate business?
I don't know.
I think it was by Osmosis from learning from hearing my dad speak about it.
I think I just absorbed the way it was supposed to be done.
Hmm.
And because of course, his talk at the dinner table was always about business.
Yeah.
And I think I must have just sort of absorbed it.
Hmm.
Did you increment work together in the early years when you were part of it?
Absolutely.
Yeah.
We did.
I remember one time we owned up that property down.
It's a corner of it's where that painting pottery painting places.
And we owned that building at one time.
And the real estate man, I remember this so vividly.
He called up and he said, did we want to sell it?
And permit put down the phone and he said, do we want to sell that?
Because there was a lot of agitation at the time that they were going to change downtown.
And the Madison Avenue Task Force was in starting and they were going to do big things.
And of course the guy that's chairman of the Madison Avenue Task Force is a very good friend of ours and still friend.
But I didn't always agree with what they were doing.
And so I said to him, you know, I think we're going to be charged a lot for doing makeover there.
And I said, one of they want to give us for it.
And so the realtor said, well, what do you take for it?
And we don't he held it a year or so.
And I said, well, 50,000 more than we want to pay for it.
And he said that my buyers will take it.
So we're 10 minute conversation.
I thought that that was a pretty good way to make 50,000 bucks.
Well, so the two of you were sort of a business team.
Yes, we were and we always kind of saw an eye on how we did it.
So forth we never had any any discussions we just talked about it.
That was it.
Go on from there.
So did he ever regret leaving me off being in an industrial engineer?
No, I don't think so.
No, I think it was very much.
I think he really enjoyed the business aspect of it.
I think so.
Sounds like he was a natural at that.
Yes.
Yeah, I'm sure he did.
So you had your first two children there in Portland?
Yes.
And then we moved down here.
And we had a house down on 10th.
And Adams.
Right by the railroad.
Pacific fruit.
You remember that?
Yeah, but we're good.
Yeah, well, it's right there.
And we bought the house because it had enough bedrooms for us to put the furniture.
And my dad was developing Cedarhurst, which is the corner of 35th.
And Harrison.
And he had, I think it's 32 acres in there.
And he developed that with a division of Ben Buren and Jackson.
And he gave us a hunk of property down on Jackson Street.
Because he'd given my brother a piece of that area between Ben Buren and Jackson.
But clear at the end of where the dairy barns were.
And of course they lived at the last house out on Harrison.
They built that when I was in high school.
So that's where we lived.
Well, after we moved back to Kermalus.
So he gave Kermalus an eye this piece of the end of Jackson.
And Kermal just took a year off and built that house.
And he built it with the help of one carpenter.
And I think he only sub-contracted.
He did the wiring.
So he sub-contracted the heating and the water.
It seems to me there was something else.
But he did all the rest of it himself because he was capable of doing that.
And I back-prime all that siding.
I would go out there after the children got up from their naps and they afternoon.
And I'd go out and they'd play in the yard.
Well, I was painting.
So we did it together, but mostly Kermalus.
Ah.
That's impressive.
Is that house still standing?
Yes.
The times lived there.
Oh yeah.
Yes.
In fact, it was written up in the paper recently.
I remember seeing your name in that article.
And how long did you live in that house then?
We lived there 35 years.
So all the way through your childhood.
I was a person he died from that house.
And I lived there six years after he died.
But you know, it was a seven bedroom house.
And it was a little big for one lady.
And so when my last one married,
I knew she wanted to be married from that house.
She's a very sentimental girl.
So as soon as she was married, then I got boy,
it's time to take care of Jean.
And so I then built this house.
I built her, I killed her, built this house.
But Kathy, in the meantime, had gotten our architectural degree.
And so she designed the house pretty much for me.
And then, killed her, built it.
Wonderful.
And so I really supervised all the building of this house.
Do you like building?
Yes, I do.
And then later I built the house at Newport.
So I built two houses.
That's impressive.
I helped.
My husband and I built our house.
And I always think I would never do that again.
But some people really enjoyed it.
Oh, I did.
I just thoroughly enjoyed it.
Yeah.
So many decisions to make.
Oh, yeah.
But I loved it.
I thought it was great.
Wonderful.
Good.
So I'm trying to envision your life here in Corvals, with four children all,
pretty close to the same ages.
Well, they were actually 10 years apart because the first three,
two years apart, then we waited four years and then had the next one.
But still you had your hands fall.
Yes, yes, I did.
I was busy with the children.
I do stop working before you had children.
Yes, I did.
But I did a lot of not only volunteering, but I did some teaching at the high school with what
do they call that?
Well, it's where you teach certain courses to adults.
I don't know what they call that now.
It used to be nice school.
Yeah.
Something like that.
But now it does have a no name you're right.
Yeah, and I don't know what that is.
But I taught penultimate jackets were very popular.
And so I taught a class on penultimate jackets.
So I taught them.
Well, penultimate jackets had a lot of the principles of solely, you know,
the pockets, but it wasn't really complicated.
Really.
But it had a lot of principles of solely.
And so I found that very much fun to teach people the basics.
Yeah.
So what kind of things did your,
do your family do?
Were you able to do some things as a group with all six of you?
Or was that really too many kids to take a little trips with and things like that?
Oh, no, we used to take the kids fishing every Sunday out of courts,
and then Bruce and Betty had a pond out of, well, it was up towards,
or was that out?
We went out to the lie and turned towards wall port and wouldn't be called that.
And how are we 34?
Yeah.
And they had some timber land out there that they had a pond on.
And there was a group of us that were quite,
it was the Jim Howellens, the R.T. Rice's, the bud crawls,
and that was, well, I guess that was at Bruce and Betty,
and we all worked together usually on Memorial Day,
4th of July, what's the other holiday?
Labor Day.
Yeah.
Have an picnic again.
Usually went out to the pond and then,
Herbert and I always took the kids and we went to,
we owned some property out, big elk,
and we went out there, crawdanting.
Oh, I got a great picture for you to put the book on the crawdant.
Oh, that felt like fun.
And then we went to ask somebody to come and eat crawdants.
We had crawdant feeds.
Seek pile of crawdants.
And then, as I say, we took the kids fishing up Quartz Creek,
and then finally we got a boat.
And by then, the rice has had a place at Triangle Lake,
and we would go down there sometimes with our boat,
and the kids' water ski.
Oh, that was fun.
That was when they were older maybe.
Yes.
So, Kermit enjoyed his family life, it sounds like.
Oh, yeah, he was a family man.
He had the meal.
He would sometimes go and get equipment from other meals
that were maybe no longer in service.
And he would say when he left, well,
I may not be back tonight because we might have trouble loading
or doing all this.
Almost always, he'd be home by midnight.
He'd never stayed over him in the place.
He'd just wanted to be there in the family.
He'd be home by the family.
I'd never had any concerns about him full after him.
That's a good thing.
He was definitely a family man.
How about summer vacations?
Did you guys ever take any trips?
Not really as summer vacations,
but we, of course, had the place up the McKinsey,
which was really nice because he had been in the three seas up there,
which I told you about it.
And so we had that in common too,
because I taught school up there.
And so when we came to having a second home,
or the second, whatever it wasn't really a home,
it was a mobile, no.
What do you call those?
Not a mobile, yeah, I guess a mobile home.
Like a trailer.
Yeah, it was a trainer like the place.
And so when we bought the property to put the trailer on,
it was up to McKinsey because we've been up there a lot,
because we liked that area.
So he had done trail building when he was there in the CCC?
Yes.
Interesting.
So that made for a good weekend getaway, probably.
Yes, it was a great place.
And the kids loved it.
They loved to fish.
We had three great fishing holes on that property.
And we liked it so well that after we had the mobile home for a while,
it was a single ride.
And we decided that we liked it well enough.
And we wanted a fireplace, because then it was cozy.
We could use it in the wintertime.
So we had him haul away that one and bring up a double ride.
Mm-hmm.
And I had that for a number of years after permit died.
But all of a sudden there was a crackhouse moved in next door.
And the people who owned that were from California.
And they rented it out.
And they brought up a lot of antiques and put in it.
Mm-hmm.
And it was just a gorgeous place.
They rented it out.
And they was a crackhouse.
And the people who had it needed wood for their fireplace.
And they burned up all the antiques.
Mm-hmm.
And I thought they'll probably be over here next.
Yeah.
And I thought this is no place for me.
So I sold it.
Mm-hmm.
And I just killed me to sell it.
I was 40 miles from any fire or police help.
Sure.
It was no place for a single woman.
Yeah.
I don't understand of them.
So I had to give it up.
And I still hate it.
Then we had to give that up.
Yeah.
Well, sounds like you had lots of good years from it.
No.
That's a fun out there.
Just have good memories.
Yeah.
It's not a good thing, too.
So you mentioned having your holidays with Bruce and Betty.
And I realized I've never asked you what the transition was from when Bruce was sort
of a nerdy kid who sat and read the ins like a video a time.
When did you start to get close to him?
Well, I think that Betty had a lot to do with that.
Because she met Bruce because I had invited her to a summer party when we were in high school.
She was going to college here.
And her father was an ROTC professor.
He was a military man.
And so Bruce offered to take her home after the smoke.
And so they were soon married.
Then we did a lot of things together.
We used to camp up at Spirit Lake where we had been our Bruce and I.
It's been our childhood.
And so we did a lot of things together.
And then after Bruce died, Betty and I traveled a lot together.
So she brought the two of you closer together.
Right there.
There's a brought him out of the house.
He became a lot more after he was in the military.
I think he became a lot more social.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's right.
Because you had told me that you saw each other a lot in San Francisco too.
Yeah, that's down there.
Yes.
That's right.
Well, I'd love to hear a little bit about your children.
Okay.
Now we're early.
Well, I guess we should start early.
Okay.
Well, can see oldest.
And he was born in Portland.
And he was a good baby.
He was a real.
We had him.
I don't know that we did we tell you.
Did we talk about the house that we had in Portland?
I'm not in great detail, no.
Well, I told you that the first house was the department in the, in the, in the safe way,
where the safe way is now in the lights in.
Well, then we moved over to the house.
The canvas born from.
It was the Westminster Presbyterian church man's.
And it was a forest story house.
A basement, a main floor.
A four bedroom.
Second floor.
And a floored attic.
And so we called it the Roth Hotel.
Because everybody came to see the, the came to Portland.
Stayed with us.
All your friends.
Well, Ken was born from there.
And then, then Craig came along.
And that was when we,
Craig was about six months old when we moved to Kervalas.
And the house that we had there was,
well, all these floors.
And it had six plugins.
Three of them, I think, were in the kitchen, or maybe four.
I would gas lights.
A sink that was weighed down here.
And I was pregnant with Craig.
And so, Kerma took out the kitchen and put in what they called a young,
young, town sink.
And it was a sink with drainboards all one piece.
And so we put it up so I could do dishes.
And then we had Craig.
And the thing that I remember about Ken,
what he was a little kid.
He had a rabbit that he loved,
stuffed rabbit.
The stuffed.
And we had a backyard that we,
a fence.
And so one day he was missing.
The lady who had been helping me with Craig had left the gate open.
Well, I was just beside myself.
So there we lived a wider, I think it was.
Anyway, it was two blocks down to Broadway.
And Harry was walking along with the holding the ears of the rabbit.
Just wandering around, having a good time.
I was just pregnant.
He was a very adventure some child.
Then Craig came along and he was born with no bicep
or no tricep, and he's left arm.
They think I had interunion and polio.
That was when polio was so just becoming something
that was everybody had to have a shot.
So Craig was never athletic.
Chris Ken was always very athletic.
But Craig was, when he'd ride a tricycle,
he could do a tricycle pretty well,
but it came to bicycles.
He couldn't balance.
Because he couldn't get that arm up.
So about, but he was in,
we moved to Kermalison.
But he was about,
I would say maybe six weeks or so,
into kindergarten.
The doctor that we had here in Kermalison,
said I want you to go down to San Francisco
and go to Stanford Medical School and see what they can do for him.
Because he'd come in at his little face.
He'd fallen off his bicycle.
You know what his face was all scarred up.
He just didn't have any balance.
So we took him down there.
And the story that I love to tell about Craig is,
We, my folks took us down to go.
We were going to fly down to San Francisco.
And it was fogged in.
And so we had to go on down and go by rail.
Well, Kermal and I were just beside ourselves.
This was a very nerve-wracking experience
for both of us to be taking this child
down to the hospital.
We didn't know what was going to be the results of this.
So because my father was a teetotler,
we didn't ever drink at home.
We always called it juice.
And so we went into have some juice in the railroad car.
And we got a coke for Craig.
And the bartender there put a cherry in it.
And so when he came, he had the operation
and came out of the anesthesia.
And he was his legs and his arms were just thrashing.
And he yelled out,
just in a loud voice,
I want a cherry in my mouth.
We were never able to tell my parents.
That's what I thought.
You might think that's such a fun story.
The little things that were just in his subconscious.
So anyway, we got through that.
And then Kathy was born.
And we were, we just expected another boy.
We were just thrilled to have this daughter.
And then Kim was born four years later.
And the girls were really quite good seamstresses.
I suppose that I taught them a lot of those things.
And they burned,
they were boo-ribbon winners for H,
for their dresses that they made.
And I think it was Kathy went on to a state fair.
And got a boo-ribbon.
They were really good seamstresses.
Still, they don't do much.
I think Kathy does more than Kim.
But they were very active in 4-H.
So were you still involved at 4-H?
Yes.
And later when I was on the 4-H,
I was a trustee for the 4-H state board.
They had.
And my dad was very instrumental in obtaining the property
for 4-H of the 4-H camp that's over near Salem.
Right.
And I was very active in that for a long time.
Were you a 4-H leader as well?
And then the children were younger?
Yes.
And I think I told you that Irma Seymour was my 4-H leader.
He always worked with him.
So I've always been active in 4-H,
and still I am to a certain extent.
We support the swimming pool at the camp.
I read that.
So interesting.
Were the boys in 4-H as well?
No, they were both equal scouts.
Oh, uh-huh.
In fact, that conversation was about that,
because my great grandson is now in scouting.
Wow.
And so I took all the scouts,
always were red, flannel, jackets.
And I happened to remember that in the cupboard out there,
I had cranks of scalp from his scouting.
Wow.
And so I gave it to my great grandchild.
And I took all the things off of it.
And it to the cleaners.
Oh, no.
It's going down there.
What's fine?
No.
That's funny.
Huh.
I think I read somewhere that Kermit was involved
with the boys scouting.
Yes.
Well, with the, uh, what, I don't know what they call that, uh,
the headquarters are in Eugene for this area.
Uh-huh.
And he was active in that management of that.
At the regional level.
I don't know what they call them trustees or what they call them.
But anyway, he was active in that for quite a while.
Wonderful.
Ah.
So as a home economist, do you think that you were, um, more prepared
than other women going into this whole childbearing thing to be able to,
I suppose so, you know, because we learned a lot of child education and what we were
supposed to do and how we were supposed to handle problems.
So that's sort of thing.
Yeah.
I think probably.
Did you continue to do the kind of things that you had been teaching
other women to do with in terms of preserving food and, um,
Well, I've always, uh, worked with the extension service to a certain extent,
um, you know, even as a volunteer, um,
and I think that I did, I followed through on a lot of that.
Yeah.
Great.
What do you think, um, was your,
your strength as a mother?
Do you think there was something that you were in the family that everybody
depended on you for?
Cooking, I think.
I think I'm good meal.
Yeah.
That's a very good meal.
Well, and I think that we cooked healthy meals because I had learned that.
You know, we always had meat and probably potatoes of some sort of
ice or starch of some sort and vegetables and salad.
My husband always wanted to salad because when he was in the service,
he didn't have any greens at all.
And he, I think we mentioned that he wanted lettuce when he's,
when he's brother came to visit.
Yeah.
And he always wanted greens.
So we always had balanced meals and we always sat down to eat together
and of course later my dad ate with us.
That, that's something that I would not do again because I don't think
it was fair to my children when you sit down to each or evening meal.
The kids want to talk about their days and my dad wanted to sort of,
he, he was the conversation list and he wanted to tell us about his day.
And I don't think it was fair to my children to do that.
Yeah.
But you know, you did what you had to do at that time.
They accommodated.
Yeah.
But it's true it's not all that common out.
I have a regular meal that itself is that.
But as a result, the Kermit came home every day for lunch from the mail
because you know, it was just a short distance.
Yeah.
And that was our quiet time together.
The two of you.
Uh-huh.
Because we hear an often, well, sometimes not, well, quite often he would bring salesman home
for lunch because the thing to do was for the salesman to take him out.
You know, try to.
Uh-huh.
Win his favor.
Yeah.
And he'd say, oh, no, let's go home.
You'll go to something.
And so I think that that's, um, that was our time together and it was also.
I always had something in the pantry like a can of chicken or I could do a
zillion things with chicken.
You know, it was chicken salad, chicken soup, chicken dumplings.
You know, there were lots of things I could do on the spur of the moment.
Do, uh, so sometimes he just call 11 30 and say, can I bring someone so
home and let's say, oh, sure, you know.
And when you say a can of chicken was that something that you had
can't?
No, no, it wasn't.
No, I didn't want anything to do with those chickens.
Yeah.
Uh-huh.
I wanted them prepared.
Yeah.
Well, that's one luxury we have now.
So, um, tell me for getting tired.
Are you still doing all right?
No, I'm still in fine, but I suppose we ought to quit around three.
All right.
I moved through this.
Um, I was, I'm almost in the same age range as your children.
So I'm thinking about the era when you were raising kids and thinking about how, um,
it was such an era of change and more permissiveness and that sort of thing from,
yeah, certainly from the era when you had been raised.
And you had been raised in such a strict way anyway.
Yes.
Was that, was that a tough transition for you to make, to figure out how to set rules
and discipline for your kids?
Well, I think that there was a lot of discipline you don't do this because
your grandfather, you know, was this way.
Uh-huh.
And the other thing that I remember vividly, and I don't remember whether I told
me this or not, but one day the teacher called me up when Kim was in school.
And, um, they, she said, we're talking about letting the girls wear pants to school.
And what did I think about it?
And I said, makes a lot of sense to me.
You know, they turned their little bottoms upside down on all the, you know,
and playground.
Yeah, on the playground thing, I said, makes a lot of sense to me.
And so that's, that's when children, because otherwise, I see pictures of my kids in
their grade school era.
And they always had dresses on.
And then all of a sudden, the pants became popular.
Uh-huh.
Yeah, I can remember when we used to have to change out of our school clothes
and to our play clothes.
Yes, that's right.
Uh-huh.
And those play clothes usually were pants.
Yeah.
I did change it a certain point.
But you got through those teenage years without that too much.
No.
My girls didn't date.
Uh-huh.
I can't date it in college, but I don't remember that.
Well, he did date when he was a senior.
But I don't remember that we had to any concerns about that.
They were pretty.
You know, they had learned.
I used to tell them, don't miss behavior because somebody knows you and somebody
who's going to paddle on you.
I see that same thing.
It's the beauty of living in a small town.
Yeah.
But they're particular stages of childhood that you enjoyed more than others.
Like, did you love that stage when they were just little and...
Yes, I did.
And I think that I probably enjoyed the girls when they were all maybe six to twelve
or something like that.
I really liked that age.
They were all enough to be talked to and sensible.
And, you know, you could kind of guide them through that period.
I really enjoyed that part of it, I think.
I'm about the boys.
Yeah.
Same.
The boys were always so active in scouting.
And I think Kermit did a lot of the parenting at that age when the boys,
because he would take in camping with the scouts.
And he would arrange to have them go and meet with other people to do their...
to get their badges.
Mm-hmm.
I think he did a lot of the parenting with the boys.
Interesting.
And of course, he'd take them to the nail.
And lots of times he'd come home if he had to go to Eugene or Portland for a partner,
something.
He would come by and grab one of the boys and take them.
And that was very helpful to me because that gave me a little freedom.
Sure.
And I remember one time he was coming back from Eugene and he and Craig were singing.
And he wasn't watching this pedometer and he got stopped.
And so the cops said something about what were they doing.
And Craig piped up and says, well, Danny, I was singing.
And the cops said, you know, if more dads would do that,
we'd be a lot better off.
You can go.
No.
Sorry, didn't I?
It's a wonderful story.
Oh.
That's interesting.
But then neither of your boys went into that field
into what products are or...
No, more scary or anything.
So I can start it out in forestry.
And then he would go out and have field trips and he'd get poison oak.
And he came back one day and he told us he said forestry isn't for me.
So I can't go to the woods.
And by that time, I think he was seeing the writing on the wall to about that it was going to go that way.
Yeah.
Uh-huh.
So he changed and went into business.
I see.
And neither of the girls was ever interested.
Oh, no.
Girls been that era.
I don't see.
They were just starting to come into the being.
I think they just had one or two girls in the forestry school.
And my dad didn't approve of that.
Yeah.
He still had a big influence on your family.
Oh, yes.
He surely did excuse me.
Sure.
Oh, who this could be?
Oh, I'm stiff from sitting there.
Oh, we've been here for a little bit.
Oh, uh-huh.
Just a package.
Okay.
Always brings the doorbell.
Uh-huh.
Didn't know what you know that he's there.
So your father was sounds like he was very influential even in your life even after
your children were born.
Oh, yes.
Uh-huh.
I think he was.
And he.
Well, you know.
He really.
He really grew old the roost because of his eating with us and.
Yeah, I would say that.
Hmm.
And the children probably had that sense.
Like you say that they were eyes all over town.
Yes.
He was going to hear about it.
Oh, he was on the school board.
You know, he knew everything that was going on.
Did I tell you the story about him?
They were trying to raise money for taxes.
The school board was.
And the man came to Lions Club and my dad was very prominent in the Lions Club.
Hmm.
He was the one who started.
I don't know if you've been reading these articles that can.
Munford's been putting in.
Yeah.
And he was one of the principles who started the.
The.
Right.
Yeah.
And.
Well, anyway.
What was I going to say about that.
Yeah.
Well, he.
He.
He was in so many.
Oh, I know.
So.
They.
The superintendent of schools.
I think it was Dr. Van Lohn.
And he came to the Lions Club and made a plea for.
Then to all vote for the increase in school property taxes.
And my dad got up and he said, well, I feel more inclined to vote for this.
He said.
Yeah.
You can keep going because the other one will catch you.
He said.
My.
My grandson was just kicked out of the first grade.
And something about one of the other kids.
Kid was kicked out of the first grade because he was a big boy.
And he had a little bit of teacher for a teacher.
And she said a note home and said that he was misbehaving.
And what was I going to do about it.
And so I went down to see about it.
And I said, what does he do?
And she said, well, he won't keep his feet under the desk.
And she said, I try putting him out in the hall.
And he just sat out there and visited with everybody and enjoyed himself.
So she said, I guess that's not the way to handle it.
And so I looked at her and I said, where does Kent sit?
And she said there.
And I said, well, you know, if you go down to the sixth grade and get a desk,
the fitting, you could probably, he probably wouldn't put his feet out.
And they, oh, oh, she said, I never thought about that.
So anyway, my dad told this story at the Lions Club.
And the old Dr. Van Loan came up afterwards and he said,
TJ, when you've got something like that, would you just come and tell me privately?
But you know, he had a lot of clout in the, because he wrote all these letters to the editor
and had an opinion on everything.
Sure.
And so the kids were pretty well, you know, if they didn't see pop, they knew somebody,
some of these friends would see them.
Yeah.
So they were pretty well.
Did I tell you that I used to worry?
He would have articles in the paper about how many timbers,
acres of timber land owned and something like this?
And I think, oh, why do you put it in the paper?
It was about the time of the Lindbergh kidnapping.
And I was so worried that somebody, you know,
Thank you.
And easy target.
Oh, yeah.
And I worried about that a lot.
Uh-huh.
But nothing ever happened.
So it was a good thing.
Yeah.
And how about your mom? Was she involved with your children?
Yes.
She was a good babysitter.
No.
And you know, she had that cart that was a golf cart.
And she would come by and they afternoon and take the kids in the golf cart.
And she had to go down to the grocery store.
She'd take them with her.
Oh, I find it.
Yeah.
So she was very much involved with the children.
I think she was more involved with Bonn and Bar,
because Bruce and Betty traveled more than we did.
And she often kept them for several weeks at a time.
And then I would kind of take them for periods of time
because I knew she needed to break.
Because, you know, she was getting older.
Yeah.
And so the boys, the boys came down and made a lot.
It's a logging road with the trucks that my husband made.
And he worked at, um, he worked at another business.
And I forgot the name of it in Portland.
But they, uh, it was during the war, uh, beginning of the war.
And, uh, the, the, the, not, not World War II.
But, um, World War II was a Vietnam.
It was next.
Probably Vietnam.
Yeah.
And he was, uh, he worked at this die casting company.
Uh-huh.
And they made log trucks, if we kids size.
And, uh, they were, the employees were, were allowed to take parts home
that were not perfect.
Uh-huh.
And so Kermit would bring them home.
And he made, I don't know, six or eight log trucks.
And these were big log trucks.
They were about like that.
Uh-huh.
And paint them.
And, uh, they had to buy the tires.
They were little tires like that.
But, uh, he would, I think, uh, can't,
these still has those log trucks.
Uh, I think that, um, he made six or eight of those.
And he would convert them to, uh, flat beds or dump trucks.
Uh-huh.
Or he, he would make little.
The dump trucks would, he, he sort of changed the configuration of some of them.
Uh-huh.
And the, uh, Bonn and Bart and Ken and Craig would make logging roads all over the place.
They, they'd love to do that.
Uh-huh.
And they would play.
And it was really no trouble for me to, to keep them,
sometimes, to give my mother a rest.
Sure.
Yeah.
Were they about the same age as your boys?
Yes.
Well, there was Craig.
Let's see.
Bonn.
Uh-huh.
Then.
Kermit came into the family.
Ken.
Then.
Bart.
Craig.
Uh-huh.
And then.
Kathy.
Uh-huh.
And then.
Kim came along later.
Uh-huh.
The boys were pretty well.
Yeah.
So they were pretty much the same age.
When.
Did you guys do holidays and things with their family?
Oh, yeah.
Christmas.
Yeah.
We always had things getting in Christmas with them.
Uh-huh.
Well, that sounds like fun.
I think you said when you were talking to Wade about Christmas that your dad was a little
shock that your holidays were more extravagant than the ones that you had had when you
were growing.
Yes.
Well, yeah.
We gave too much to the children.
Uh-huh.
And I'm saying the same thing about mine.
And regeneration probably feels that way.
Yeah.
Well.
But it's so much fun to indulge them.
Um.
I did have some questions about traveling.
Do you have a little energy?
Just five or three now.
Would you like?
Could I have a little bit more about traveling?
Uh-huh.
You talked a little bit about your trip that the two of you took to Japan and that kind of thing.
Um.
And I'm.
You didn't take any trips with the children during that time when they were growing up.
Oh, yes.
We took them to Hawaii for several times.
And uh.
But we didn't ever take them farther than that.
I don't think.
Why is it big trip for a family of six?
Yes.
Yes, it was.
It was quite a.
Quite a.
John.
Yeah.
And uh.
What island did you go to when you went there?
Oh.
I think we went to the big island because we went up to the volcano.
We thought that was educational.
Yes.
Yeah.
And uh.
And then can would sometimes come by himself or Craig when they were a little bit
older.
But we'd take the two girls and then we took the two girls to Australia.
But this was when when the boys were older and out.
Ken was married and.
Craig was.
Or was Craig.
I guess maybe he was married to when we took the girls to Australia.
Mm-hmm.
What inspired a trip to Australia?
How did you choose that?
Well, no.
What made us go to Australia?
I think we just started wanting to go.
Kermit always wanted to go that direction.
He never wanted to go to Europe.
Mm-hmm.
I think we just thought that was a good place to go.
Yeah.
And I think Kathy wanted to go.
She wanted to go.
It was the time they were building the music center.
We're like opera house in Melbourne.
And I think that she was very interested in the way that was constructed.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
It's an amazing thing.
Because Kermit and she spent one whole day of our trip.
Photographing it and walking around it and going through it.
And she did a report for class at Oregon State and got some credits for doing all of that.
So she knew from the very beginning that she wanted to be at.
And I guess she did.
She loves our protector.
Mm-hmm.
Wonderful.
What does your younger daughter do?
She's, she wanted to be a nurse.
Mm-hmm.
But she met her husband instead.
And so then she took education.
Oh.
She's been a school teacher and a substitute teacher.
Mm-hmm.
That's wonderful.
But she didn't, she never was a regular teacher.
Because when they were married, she twins quite early in her married life.
Mm-hmm.
And so I think she just did substituting.
But she loves teaching.
Mm-hmm.
So you've stayed very close with your children.
It sounds like.
Oh, yeah.
As adults, your parents don't know.
No, they're here now.
Come and mold or here.
Huh.
That's right.
Because they're building the courtyard.
The courtyard.
Mm-hmm.
Are you involved with that project?
Well, somewhat.
Yeah.
I...
When they get in a bind, I help them out.
Mm-hmm.
Not only financially, but otherwise too sometimes.
Because you have that experience with dealing with contractors and real estate things.
Mm-hmm.
Have you worked with any of your other children on construction projects or real project?
No.
They're all kind of very handy.
Like he's daddy's.
Very he can do anything.
Mm-hmm.
And, uh, Craig's pretty handy.
But he's, uh, his recreation consists of hunting and fishing.
Mm-hmm.
That's something they used to do with their dad to the hunting.
Oh, yes.
Oh, he's got their deer.
Mm-hmm.
We had some forest lands out here.
And we, uh, reserved that for family hunting.
Mm-hmm.
And, uh, so that there were other people shooting around him.
Good idea.
And, uh, yeah.
So, uh, they've always hunted and fished.
Mm-hmm.
That can doesn't do that much, but Craig does a lot too much.
Well, I think it's admirable that you're still so close with everybody.
Mm-hmm.
Well, I think we're, we're as close as, you know, we talk probably every week.
At least, sometimes, you know, if there's something going on, we talk every other day.
But, you know, just like Gary called me, you know, he, you know, he wants, but he, he calls me every once in a while.
Well, that's my grandson.
Your grandson.
So, yeah.
It's kind of nice.
Yeah.
Absolutely.
And it sounds like you must have been the kind of mother that everybody was sort of comfortable with.
Well, I guess they were.
Because they sure, uh, you know, they keep in touch.
Mm-hmm.
That's nice thing to be able to say.
Yeah.
Good.
Well, we could take a break here as he'd like.
All right.
Next time, we'll go on to talking a little bit about, uh, more about your community work.
And we can, you know, we can start back in these days when you were involved with your kids and trying to work.
Yeah.
I had a couple of things here about, uh, when we lived over on Jackson Street, but we had a, uh, I, uh,
Holly, the whole, the whole role of Holly trees.
And so every Christmas, we trimmed the Holly trees.
And then the girls would put them put the clippings in the wheelbarrow.
And they'd go up and down Jackson Street and ask anybody if they wanted Holly for Christmas.
Uh-huh.
They just gave it to them, you know.
Oh, sweet.
So that was kind of nice.
Uh-huh.
That was a holiday tradition, huh?
Did you have some other holiday traditions that were different or leftover from your growing up years?
Uh-huh.
Oh, I don't know that we, we certainly had food that was very traditional, but, uh, we always had turkey
and always had dressing and, uh, I could tell you some funny stories about that.
And so it putting, uh, that was carrot, putting, steam, putting.
Uh-huh.
And, uh, interesting.
And we usually had boiled onions, a little pearl onion.
Uh-huh.
And, uh, cranberry ice.
They always had that.
Uh-huh.
As in ice cream?
What is cranberry ice that is there?
Oh, no.
It's a ice that you eat with meat.
Uh-huh.
You know.
Here to that.
Oh, very fancy dinner has the clear-year palate.
Uh-huh.
So I could change it.
Is it shaped in both?
No.
We always just made it, uh, um, you know, with a beater and then we scoop it out and put it in, uh,
in a little sherbet dish.
Uh-huh.
And that was served with the, uh, all the hot things.
Okay, turkey.
Sweet potatoes.
Candied sweet potatoes.
Um-huh.
Mashed potatoes and gravy.
Uh-huh.
Standard menu.
Always.
Still is.
Except for the sweet pudding.
I haven't heard of anybody making sweet pudding in a very long time.
Well, we always made carrot pudding.
That was, but it's made with sweet.
Uh-huh.
And, uh, uh, uh, uh, what do they call the stuff you put on the top of the, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh,
how you make it, ship with sugar and egg and.
Marine?
What?
No.
Uh-huh.
Why can't I think of the name?
I guess I haven't thought of it since last year.
Uh-huh.
She's an egg and it's not Marine.
Well, I can't think of what, what it is now that we always put on top of it.
I can, I can still see my mother sitting in front of the fireplace.
Before we had beaters, you know, and she would whip that stuff.
You're good for ever to make.
No, Marshmallow.
No.
Uh-huh.
Did we talk about the Burlington family and Uncle Gus?
No, but I'd love to hear about them.
You didn't, we didn't, well, we've got to talk about it.
I know you talked a way about Uncle Gus bringing you raisins as a kid.
Yeah, well, that's, but we've done that thing.
Uh-huh.
Well, I just, uh, the date that, um, uh, I think I was going to look up some dates for you.
And Kermit died at 59 and he died in 1979.
Had he been ill at all before that?
Well, not, you know, he, he always was not just, well, we didn't, I think that we always thought that he was fragile,
but, you know, but didn't realize what it was.
You know, in those days, heart things were, it was very different then.
Yeah.
Well, we made a big strides in heart.
Well, I guess that's all I had on my little.
Sometimes I wake up in the middle of the night and I think, oh, we need to talk about this.
Yeah.
That's a good thing.
I thought you took notes and, and if you think about it, things definitely bring them in.
Yeah.
So, so, Kermit died just of, of a sudden heart attack?
Yes.
Uh-huh.
He was just fine.
And he, we had come back from a trip to Mexico and, uh, he went down.
He was building a photography studio in the basement.
And he thought he'd take up photography's kind of a application.
Mm-hmm.
And, uh, he came upstairs and he said, uh, are you ready to go and do errands downtown?
And I said, yeah, I'm ready just as soon as I finish this note.
I said, I'm writing, thank you's to the people that they're nice to us to.
In Mexico and, uh, all of a sudden, I looked over and he was laid out on the bed.
And I said, Kermit, what's the matter?
And, uh, he just kind of looked at me, you know.
And I went over and I felt his forehead and it was just sweaty.
Mm-hmm.
And, uh, I said, what is the matter?
I said, I think I better call the doctor and he said, yes, I guess so.
And, uh, I think he knew what he had.
Mm-hmm.
But I didn't at the time.
And, uh, so I called the doctor and he said, getting to the hospital, getting to the hospital.
And so I said, can you walk out to the car?
And he said he thought he could.
So he did.
Mm-hmm.
Then he threw up and, you know, I ran to get a pan so that we could, if he threw up again,
Why?
We could, didn't need to stop and we got him out to the hospital.
And some little man came up.
I didn't know him from Adam.
And I think he thought that he, that I knew who he was.
He apparently was the heart doctor and I didn't know him from Adam.
And as Ollie said to me, he says, your husband's a very sick man.
Mm-hmm.
And I thought, well, what's he sick about?
You know?
Yeah.
I said, well, can I see him?
And he said, yeah, I'm going to see him.
But I'm still in know they had a heart attack.
Mm-hmm.
And, uh, so he lived that day.
And then the next day they took him to Portland,
Oh, hey, just you.
And it was February.
And it was, I see, oh, there was this much ice on the streets everywhere.
Mm-hmm.
And I didn't think we'd ever make it uphill.
But the ambulance, I don't know if they had chains or not.
But they made it up the hill.
Mm-hmm.
And, uh, I knew he was very sick when they, then they made everybody get out of the elevator
and let us in.
Mm-hmm.
I knew that there was something bad going on.
So he just lived that night.
And he was gone the next day.
Mm-hmm.
So, my life changed.
Yeah.
I'm like a really sudden change.
You never know what the future brings.
So you better live every day.
Yeah.
Well, sounds like he did live.
He sounds like he enjoyed his life.
Oh, he did, he enjoyed every day.
Yeah.
And let's have good hobbies and travel and stuff.
Let's go to a short.
Mm.
Well, thank you for telling me about that.
Yeah.
I'm eager to talk to you too about, um,
I try to imagine you stepping into,
well, taking over there at the property business and that sort of thing at that point.
I guess you had been so involved that it wasn't that big of a lead.
No, it wasn't because I think he had a premonition all the time that he would,
that I would outlive him because my family had, you know, sort of an older,
reputation of whatever.
And his family had always died suddenly.
And so he, he was pretty insistent that I be aware of everything that was going on in financial things.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
We always talked over every deal.
Mm-hmm.
So I just went on from there.
We just picked right up and kept moving with it.
Uh-huh.
Mm-hmm.
Good.
Next, next time I'd like to talk more about, um,
not only your community activism.
I have said many times that hate is like an asset that does as much damage to the vessel in which it is stored as to the object on which it is poured.
Mm-hmm.
The other one is Gem of the Day when the tide of life turns against you and the current,
and the current, current upsets your boat.
Don't waste tears on what might have been just lie on your back and float.
That's so wonderful.
Those are two things that I look at.
Yep.
We're still alive.
Beautiful.
Thank you.
Keep all that stuff there, handy.